marvel's own god of mischief-centered
series loki
just wrapped up its freshman season and
fans have loved the time bending thrill
ride
nicely connected to other films in the
marvel cinematic universe
set after the events of avengers end
game loki adds additional layers to the
already complex world of heroes and
villains
and the season finale reveals just
enough information to get fans excited
about loki season 2.
the sixth and final episode of season 1
finds loki and sylvie reaching the
citadel at the end of time
and by the end of the episode they meet
a major marvel villain
the enigmatic he who remains a variant
of king the conqueror whom sylvie ends
up murdering after shoving loki through
a portal perhaps more surprisingly one
of the loyal subjects to he who remains
is identified at the very beginning of
the episode and it's a reveal many fans
had theorized about since the start of
loki
one of the newer characters introduced
to the mcu in loki
is miss minutes an animated
anthropomorphic
clock who serves as both an assistant
and mascot of the time
variance authority her sweet southern
drawl and emphasis on manners and rules
may seem wholesome at first
but many fans had a lingering feeling
that she isn't as innocent
as she appears and as it turns out those
fans were correct
in the first few moments of the season 1
finale loki and sylvie are greeted by
the creepily cheerful miss minutes
who reveals her loyalty to he who
remains and her behind-the-scenes
workings with the tva
while each loki episode usually sends
the internet into a frenzy anyway
this final episode lit up social media
even more
thanks to its big reveals tons of fans
stick to twitter to joke about how
creepy miss minutes was in her initial
jump scare
likening her to a horror movie monster
one twitter user wrote that they didn't
see the miss minutes reveal coming
though there have been
fan theories about her true evil nature
floating around the internet as early as
june according to sites like inverse
whether you saw this reveal coming or
not the season one finale of loki has
opened the doors for many more exciting
adventures in season two
and we can't wait to see what happens
next after the reveal that miss minutes
is actually an important henchmen to the
two big bads of loki
kang and renslayer fans were left
shocked that this cheerful animated
character was a bad guy in disguise
however miss minutes is still a pretty
fascinating character
thanks to her top-notch animation and
tara strong's excellent vocal
performance
and since the mcu loves bringing back
popular characters it's definitely
possible that this cute tva mascot may
pop up in future marvel films and
television shows
according to an interview on marvel's
own website miss minutes was a favorite
amongst these show's creators as well as
its fans
which meant that the creative team
behind loki cooked up ways to keep her
as
involved in the narrative as possible
director kate herron revealed
early on in the scripts we all were
definitely united on we've got to keep
miss minutes in the story somehow
head writer michael waldron agreed
saying she was a really fun way to
deliver some pretty heady exposition
there's something sing-songy and sort of
non-threatening about the way she talks
but yet when it turns and when she
becomes evil suddenly it's
really scary in fact miss minutes
originally had even more to do as
waldron explained including a daring
fight scene
which sadly hit the cutting room floor
waldron told marvel that the show's
writers crafted miss minutes as a
character that would serve as
that devil on the shoulder and trying to
tempt both loki and
sylvie it was fun that you got a sense
of there's something a bit more sinister
going on here with her
he also revealed a scene that ultimately
never came to pass we always had a
version where loki and sylvie kept
meeting her at the citadel
at one point we had a fight scene with
miss minutes in the citadel we had all
kinds of stuff for her
the first season of loki is streaming in
its entirety on disney plus now
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows and movies are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one